a delegation from Parliament civil
liberties committee arrived in Lebanon
this week to see how the small eastern
Mediterranean country is coping with the
massive influx of refugees from Syria
they met a Lebanese minister responsible
for dealing with the crisis the UN
refugee agency and of course refugees
themselves we have a very extreme
situation we have wanted to have million
refugees pouring in from Syria we have a
pre-existing situation of Palestinian
refugees already here we have
integration problems of the Lebanese
population we really have to understand
whether that is just financial aid or we
have to understand whether destiny will
resettlement or relocation of refugees
otherwise we're going to have big
problems responsibility sharing a
distribution key a better assessment
policy better relocation we know we're
not getting those rights in the European
Union but for the sake of the region for
Lebanon we need to get that right it is
completely obvious but the Syrian crisis
a ceasefire has to happen because that
continual suffering is feeding into this
almost global nightmare facing the small
country Lebanon we're not making big
promises but we want to have a deeper
understanding so that we go back to the
European Parliament and we have a better
set of policies we invited members of
the lebanese parliament to come to the
european parliament also make their case